[Applaudissements]
des images des applaudissements lors du
show du refuge de l'an dernier ça se
passait à la place des arts c'était le
27e le 28e s'en vient dans quelques
jours spectacle bénéfice qui permet
d'amasser de l'argent pour le refuge des
jeunes de montréal
je reçois danby grand instigateur du
spectacle porte parole de l'organisme
dont jordan à l'eau et elle est beaucoup
d'émotion l'an dernier vous venez juste
de subir une opération en raison du
cancer
ouais mon dribble gauche fasse le show
est très faisable ou avait conseillé mon
jeu de mots lensois livre mais chose
d'obliger parce que si on fait pas chaud
ferme
et puis ça s'est bien passé pour marc
adapte être quelque chose d'un peu le
bout du port toute belle faute au delà
d'ailleurs vous recevoir l'année passée
à ce moment ci
mais bon vous aviez fait des choix bien
sûr comment va la santé tout d'abord
rapidement bas sur tr min un genre
l'émission donc je le suivis pendant ses
quatre chats tout l'été symptôme qui
m'ont pas détester tout ça mais moi pas
avoir ma vie garantie c'est normal
personne n'ose avis et là dessus on peut
tout ce fatras peut pas être certain de
ce fait que ce soit ça se vit très bien
mais tu vois si j'avais pas un choix
d'être là pour le show du refuge de l'an
passé pour vous là c'est plus qu'un
spectacle bénéfice mission de vie le
refuge des jeunes oui quand j'ai quand
j'ai dit oui je les prix comme une
mission de vie évidemment d'un stage
avait pour monter le taux de 100 dans
mon alcool fait que j'ai pas été cru
tout de suite mais je pense que là il
commence à se douter joue avec le beau
temps sec avec du thym et la face
hideuse aviez amasser un montant record
un demi million de dollars pour les
jeunes à quoi ça sert ces sommes là que
vous amassez chaque année
il ya deux volets le premier volet bien
sûr on est un centre d'urgence fois être
pris comme ça après ça quand genève
entre email à celle écoute qui commence
il faut savoir quelle sorte de service
on va donner après il ya d'autres choses
qui s'enclenche le sport juste les soins
de santé d'hygiène pour moi j'ai comme
il faut se reposer sur tout c'est les
démarches qui sont pris ce qui serait
capable de se trouver un job elle s'est
déshabillée il leur donne un peu
d'argent un billet d'autobus des choses
comme ça les choses c'est après ça dans
le plus long terme il ya on a on avec 9
unités de logements sociaux la ville
aussi il ya des gens qui peuvent
fonctionner en appartement c'est il ya
des jeunes qui viennent refuge même
temps des gens qui ont les premiers
santé mentale slim est seul dans une
chambre d'un appartement ça se peut
qu'on retrouve pendu sont rodés espérait
finaliser muse refuge pour être au moins
en gagne pas seule il y en a un qui
reviennent à noël je soupe à noël sont
route ils reviennent mais inutile et des
logements sociaux une coupe de l'est
retour qui se fait je m'en donner du
fruit remettre au préfet l'a prescrit
pour chercher leur propre appartement à
pire c'est beaucoup plus que les besoins
d'urgence manger et dormir là c'est une
prise en charge la plus longue possible
finalement qu'un oui mais il faut
commencer par l'urgence n'est pas
l'urgence juste l'urgence fac tu as un
autre affaire toutes les jeunes se
demande pas ce que c'est c'est quoi
commencer oui c'est la grosse grosse
grosse des traces et six mois je prends
à rully lévis madame de nos joueurs sont
des blessures mal soignées par ta maison
tu divorces tu te bats ta job tu vois je
démissionne on peut lire un peu de ce
que je veux pas généraliser mais les
jeunes la mer sont son barreau et elop
et son bar où était depuis l'enfance
saison personne leur dire qu'ils payent
quelque chose qu'ils sont dignes d'amour
fait qu'elles n'ont pas pu parce que
c'est normal il passe c'est normal qu'on
désarme pas alors des gens jusqu'à savez
je me sens une certaine importance vous
m'écoutez
donc c'est quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose auquel on est habitué aux
autres nous aurons s'écoute pas qu'on se
parle le l'autre eux on passa alors
cessé de le redonner une dignité en
diabète et xu pour moi il est déjà sur
place et là c'est le début à ce moment
là d'une démarche parce que lors il va
la perdre sur quelqu'un donc sont plus
intéressés il va faire quelque chose on
lui laissait mourir un petit peu tous
les jours est passée par là vous même
ouais c'est un peu moins piémont fallait
que je quitte la maison parce que c'est
pas drôle mais ça fait longtemps
oui ça fait longtemps soit 45 ça fait
très longtemps et a pas de refuge on
allait des fois c'est à québec
d'installer au pire on allait on allait
l'armée du salut des fois quand elle est
vraiment aucune place je reste ici pour
moi c'est la rue mais on a maintenant
des parties finissaient plus on
s'organise et puis la musique me très
très très vite ressource eau vavi mène à
lui je n'ai pas eu trop tôt trop copag
aux gens ce qu'ils ont maintenant c'est
quand on lit votre biographie quand même
c'est un long chemin de croix
quand même belle autant que soit le fond
de panier vite oui si certains qui
durera du retard à rattraper ça fait
partie du décor j'ai commencé par un
cintre indien biographie pour qu'on
comprenne ce qu'est ce que je refuse par
exemple c'est pas de la générosité c'est
de mon chemin passe par là j'ai besoin
et moi aussi
c'est un échange mais j'ai pas suis
départ et j'en fais affaire dure mais je
suis pas encore leurs martyrs puis j'ai
encore mes parents me disent on tue plus
de ce monde
et puis ça a été les affaires du met qui
était parsemé l'argent lui-même ma
biographie les gens m'écrivent mais
direction mort de rire la moitié du
temps aussi
c'était sur ma vie aussi in this one et
de la musique ivoirienne à voir sur la
scène pour le show du refuge c'est jeudi
donc je dis qu'ils viennent salle
wilfrid-pelletier la place des arts
rapidement en terminant qui sont les
artistes comme avant sur scène j'ai yama
mais le pro cloutier même les josé
l'ancien cousineau qui était un autre
chanteur soprano votre et lyrics d'un
épi droit quand même d'un match nul ou
quartz jeu séjoumi quelqu'un qui
j'aimerais que l'irlande
serra parce que quand je parle du jour
je suis pas encore trop ce qu'on va
faire
là aussi on a tout répéter tout est pas
mal et je sais juste de faire tourner un
peu comme on dit à la générale fait que
je sais dire l'observateur rockets sait
lire et qu'en même temps sa première
année qui des fois on a un petit bout
comme sûre mais on a pas mal de buts
excellent puis on va pouvoir voir les
choses de refuge ces récits radio canada
télé le dimanche 16 décembre à 20h sur
j'essaye de ne pas trouver là non c'est
parce qu'ils recevront un coup de
billard à certaines pourront trouver
preneur d'un demi-gramme merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là ce matin beaucoup
remercie